this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
good afternoon welcome to e3 a Stanford
computer systems colloquium fall 2012
2013 the course organizers for Dennis
Allison and Andy Freeman and they're
both out of town so you get me today
today we have Richard Palmer from
Juniper Networks they make the year that
holds the net together and the
interesting thing about the network is
that it's not stable how many of you
guys saw the stable over time shooting
how many of you guys saw the doubler
cartooning last Sunday yeah it's really
good go look it up the buzzword is clog
wash yes it's it's classic Dilbert it's
great and if you want if you have a
different sense of you but well the neat
thing I was 20 back over over from
Donner summit 10 years ago and we took
the back road for a ways and we found a
construction project that slowed us down
and they were putting a pipe you know
this big in and it's not a gas pipe it
was the fiber pipe if they were just
putting in the steel pipe I assume
somebody's going to come along later and
fill it full of fibers but I did the
back of the envelope calculation and
came up with you know if you put half
the u.s. population on each side of the
Donner summit you know that was still
the gigabit each right all right please
welcome Richard Palmer
so that's a great lead-in and I was at
an event actually here at campus last
week called the the revolution of
Software Defined Networking and
individual in the program here came up
to me and said you know there aren't any
problems left us all the networking
we've we figured it all out it's just
you know we gave everybody I could give
it to their house to their phone and
we're done and and people that design
networks and for the past about 15 years
I've been calling on on any customers
because big enterprise customers like
Boeing and and the standard for the
university itself here I is a customer
of mine and helping them build these
networks out so more people can access
more and more services and so challenge
is is that is is not that even the first
mall the last mile whatever you wanna
call it anymore to the to the device or
to the home it's it's what it all gets
into the big data centers where you know
run by the Facebook's and the Google's
the yahoos the big companies that want
to serve up these rich applications how
do they manage all of that
simultaneous demand right and and part
of it's called cloud computing so let me
talk a little bit about about how we got
to where we are kind of it I think it's
it's informative because in a lot in
technology in general but especially in
networking it's hard to leave behind
what you started with right and and big
companies like Microsoft and Cisco faced
this problem as well right you you want
to innovate you want to build new things
but your customers sometimes some of
your customers were just fine with what
you had 20 years ago and so it's hard to
do a clean break and although people are
working on that as well as another
program here at Stanford it might be
filled with the clean slate program it's
actually a group of researchers that are
looking into you know how do we design
the network if we could start all over
again and and that's actually where the
concept and software to find out what he
came out of so I put up a little a
little my view of a timeline about about
how network design has evolved that kind
of informs this this dialogue and
obviously this goes back further to to
ARPANET which is where we first came up
with packet based networks right and
Ethernet which goes back into the 70s
but it was about the mid 80s where
organizations again universities big
companies started to build data networks
and they started to digitize the work of
their of their employees people who
do typewritten reports or you know if
there were engineering architecture firm
they would do drawings and people
started to digitize that work CAD and
word processing were the were the early
applications for for desktop machines
and the early networking was 10base5 and
it was it was a bust technology right he
had one basically one long cable and
everybody tapped into that one long
cable pretty easy topology pretty easy
to troubleshoot you just followed the
cable along right oh there's the bad one
and in the early 90s we actually figured
out we actually figured out how to run
that ethernet over twisted pair of wire
and the the original Ethernet 10 base T
was actually able to run over what we
call now call cat 3 which at the time
was used for business phones and so it
was very convenient a lot of that wiring
already existed in in big again campuses
whether they be academic government or
business and you could now run data over
that existing existing wire and people
started to do it with other things with
the network the Tim berners-lee
developed the idea of the world wide web
initially just text-based obviously and
people started to obviously emails been
back to the beginning of ARPANET but but
regular folks if you were all started to
use email around this time and in the
early 90s was when a bunch of companies
working out of the first Interop IPO
it's a Cisco IP ode companies called
that I'd never heard of because it had
been around for a while well flea
communications and office communications
cable Tron these companies all IP and
about 89 90 and they wanted to
commercialize these networks and and and
build a business out of it and so those
early networks were very much for for
organizations right we really hadn't
thought in terms of consumers yet and so
and one piece so this is Moore's law and
I'm sure people that are that come to
classes with Iggy and the Tyler familiar
with Moore's law but it also effects you
know things that we do in the network
world as well right because we also can
leverage the number of transistors
transistors on a CPU to build bigger and
faster network hardware and so that's
really the the back
to this this whole timeline is is is
Moore's law right and this this this
line can be not just transistors on a
processor but this is the number of
routes on the internet it's the number
of hosts texted to the network it that's
all grown over time but back in again
when these companies IPO and when we
first got the first ether switched
company called Kalpana we came up with
that took 10 base T and figured out how
to connect a lot of users simultaneously
wasn't too long before we started to
build networks that looked a lot like
this it's called a tree it's called a
three-tier architecture the three tiers
being starting with the the servers in
either a big campus or data center
called the access tier and and that tier
of devices connects to the next year
which is called the distribution tier
and then in again the so-called classic
network design you have the core so the
three-tier architecture and based on
what people were doing and how they were
going about it right the pretty static
content
static applications a lot of file
sharing again email not not too heavy
demands on on the network infrastructure
and so this this design works pretty
well the the servers again back in this
early design these are pretty much
physical server server virtualization
didn't come around actually until about
until the year 2000 I should say x86
server virtualization for the computer
historians they'll know that IBM
developed that idea a long time ago but
it it really became popular for
commercializing on x86 environments when
VMware can put the idea to do it on x86
servers
so building on that the mid-90s things
really started to change the windows 95
put put a pretty useful GUI in a lot of
people's hands not just and they started
to grow beyond the business environment
now now people at home might have a
computer with a GUI on it Marc
Andreessen of course at at and as part
of NCSA worked on the mosaic browser to
take this idea of the world wide web and
take it out of just the text-based world
and be able to add rich content pictures
and videos and lots of other things and
again make it more accessible to a very
the average user and also the kind of
the beginning of what we now call the
dot-com boom right Netscape IPO taking
that that browser that Andreessen had
and taking in Driessen and
commercializing that netscape IP owed
ebay IPO and amazon appealed so all of a
sudden now you've got a lot more people
want to access these rich network
resources or actually users don't
usually want to access the network they
want to access the neat stuff on the
network right and and that's where the
bottlenecks happen is that you have lots
of users which aren't really shown on my
network design and you have lots of
services or servers and it's it's how we
coordinate that communication between
all the users and all the services that
makes Network design a challenge around
around y2k of course there was the y2k
but we also sped up Ethernet again
getting to the gigabit you were talking
about earlier and which is you know back
then was really high speed and expensive
and now it's I can have it on my macbook
air right with a little $29 dongle so
but it's that part of it is evolving our
had evolved fairly rapidly if I had the
actual dates on here you'd see that the
time between 10 base T and 100 base T
was quite a while from ten to one was
not - it was a short amount of time from
1 to 10 was very short
we now have 40 and a hundred the next
leap is going to be it's going to be
pretty tough again if you follow
ethernet standards basically you're only
able to get packets so close together
and and have frequencies go so fast
right
basically when you get beyond 10 if you
look at the underlying technology really
all we're doing is is multiplexing
multiple 10-gig paths on a single piece
of fiber or a fiber bundle so we've
actually kind of at least from a change
in the fundamental technology Ethernet
we've kind of hit a roadblock we will
still have faster speeds but again
faster speeds don't necessarily deliver
better service especially as more users
right are mobile
I've probably I'm tying up five IP
addresses here on the desk between my
mobile provider and the guest wireless
network here at Stanford and so I'm not
even burning up a single Ethernet port
here in the room the the mid-80s things
I'm sorry the mids the mid part of the
last decade is when things really took a
very different turn the the idea of
server virtualization started to be used
by big companies then of course the
iPhone was introduced and now all of a
sudden the accessing the network
resources become decoupled from a
physical connection or even a physical
place and more importantly that the
iPhone didn't just give you mobile
internet right the the iPhone and and
obviously following on other smartphones
you have multiple sensors on these
devices right I've got a camera I've got
a GPS and so the things that I want to
do and again a lot of creative people
here in other places have come up with
apps that combine all these sensors into
into an interesting output right things
like Yelp where I want to have I want to
have restroom reviews for the restaurant
I'm walking by right think about all the
that you're not the information that has
to be processed for you to get to that
information right and that happens back
in these data centers well this this
design doesn't really hold up anymore
again I want to access a lot of rich
content I want to I want to create rich
content and I want to I don't want to
have to wait for it and and this this
three-tier design doesn't work in a
virtualized environment where the number
of users is growing file it's stripping
the ability of this this legacy network
to support it
so it was a little while ago so this
this graph is showing it was actually
about five years ago the number of
servers that are virtual is that has
actually surpassed the number of servers
that are physical and that introduces a
many challenges for network designers
again back back in in the day if you
will with this this three-tier design
where pretty much everything was
physical from the the switches to the
storage fire everything was physical and
you could actually if there was a Fault
in the in the environment you could
pretty much go back to just racing
things it's like I must be over here I
can just follow this piece of cable once
you start virtualizing everything from
servers to to storage to firewalls
that's no longer possible and it not
only is it no longer possible but the
the things that people want to do with
the virtual servers are different
because now I've abstracted my operating
system of my applications away from the
physical hardware why should I be tied
to the physical environment and and
that's again opened up both a lot of
possibilities for for application
designers but it's opened up a lot of
challenges for Network designers because
we can no longer count on that server
remaining where it is physically in the
dentist' center it could be across the
data center it could be to add a backup
data center it could be across the
country following the user demand
another another element that has really
altered the way that networks are
designed if you looked back at that that
tree architecture that it really was
designed with going going back to the
first networks which were about campuses
it kind of had a geographic basis and
the first networks were to connect you
know knowledge workers to a fixed set of
resources whether it's email servers or
file share servers and people thought in
terms of well I've got floors on a
building
I've got buildings on the campus and
then I've got a campus core and that's
that that three-tier architecture
followed sort of that geographic mindset
well as you can see this is currently
how large datacenters that the
percentage of traffic and where it's
going so that really big slice is
actually traffic
of servers talking other servers or
applications talking to their
applications so I gave the example of
Yelp and again you could think of a lot
of a lot of applications that in order
to disturb up the content to you your
Facebook page they're pulling in ads
that they think are relevant to you
they're pulling in your friends updates
right there's a lot of processing that's
going on before it's presented to to the
end user and that processing happens
within the data center and before
whatever is handed out to you so if I've
designed my network with this this
Geographic mindset where I've got a
bunch of users accessing a set of fix
that are resources that the old
three-tier architecture it's very
inefficient because you have to what
happens is a lot of my traffic we call
east-west in in these larger data
centers a lot of these applications are
talking to each other before they they
deliver up the results to the person
that requested it and this this tiered
architecture is very inefficient because
in the old days we would have a given
number of servers on a subnet if you
wanted to talk to a different server you
had to pass a routing boundary or what
we call their three boundary in order to
get there and in in networking usually
the higher up the OSI model that you go
from physical to delink layer to the IP
layer and the higher up you go usually
the more CPU cycles it takes to do any
any interesting processing and so if I
just want to again collect all this data
I want to look in the database I want to
pull up some some video files some
static pictures and serve that all up as
unify content I want to keep the
processing to a minimum so you're not
something that are waiting for this to
happen right again it's it's a very
competitive digital economy now and you
know those that provide the best service
are going to have the most users whether
they're paying users or whether their
eyeballs to sell to advertisers or that
it's a lot of competition to provide
that that user experience and so this
this model breaks down
I put this up here just again for those
art that I know most people have virtual
machines on their on their laptops now
I'm sure is a pretty common technology
but I wanted to just put it up as a
reminder what do you know what is a
virtual machine and also what is what is
V motion which is that that what
virtualized environments want to do with
those virtual machines is not just
leverage the horsepower on this physical
server right so you know why has has
virtualized x86 servers become popular
again getting back to Moore's law
especially legacy applications that were
written for you know say a CPU of 10
years ago if the application hasn't
changed much over time and now I can I
can get a server with you know 64 cores
in 128 gig of ram it's going to have
that that physical server about you know
half percent utilization which is a
which is a huge way huge waste which is
what drives people to to virtualize and
you know once you've done that now
you've opened up first of all you get
you know from the economic perspective
I've got better utilization on my
physical Hardware but now now you say
well why should I be tied geographically
to where the physical Hardware is if I
want to have a load sharing environment
so that I can I can again follow the Sun
if you're a global company like Facebook
and Google you know I want to have some
of my application servers move around
real-time I want to do it for backup and
they don't have to shut down the OS in
order to do that it's called live
migration or V motion and that puts
again a new kind of stress on the
network this technology the way it's
been developed so far actually doesn't
work across layer three boundary so I
need to enable a much I need one able my
layer two environment to stretch much
broader than it ever did before and
again having to cross those layer three
boundaries doesn't work doesn't support
this technology but it also the the
latency that it introduces is
detrimental to the environment as well
this is sort of REM ffice izing the the
idea of east-west traffic again it's
hard to overemphasize it because that's
really what's driving some of the things
that I want to talk about about the the
challenges that the industry and and
academia right now is
trying to figure out about how we enable
these things because you know the things
that we're doing today they're solving
part of the problem but there's still a
lot left to do and sorry there we go
so we have this virtualized data center
we have companies again like Facebook
like Zynga and even big enterprises that
have want to be able to move their their
services around the network seamlessly
it's the the current architecture both
both network architecture and even you
know the virtual architecture if you
consider virtual LANs is wasn't built to
scale to the numbers that people are
trying to support and I tried to sort of
consolidate a bunch of different things
that people are doing to solve different
different elements of this of this
virtual data center the first one is the
virtual switch itself and so if you
think back to that that layer so just
put back up there so this is the way
that most most hypervisors work and I'm
using VMware as an example obviously
there's other people that make
hypervisors so this piece is actually a
virtual Ethernet switch so not only have
I taken the servers and virtualize them
and put them many of them and this can
be this is showing three I think the
average is 12 but but some environments
they have up to a hundred virtual
machines on a single physical server and
the first network hop is actually inside
that physical server and that introduces
a couple of challenges it introduces the
challenge that VMware is not really a
networking company they've done a decent
job but there that's not there their
core skill and so what happens is that
it's typically that the device they're
providing that that virtual switch isn't
managed like a regular switch and also
from a organizational perspective in
these in large organizations right the
network people are their own domain and
server people are their own domain and
there's the question of who configures
the switch on the server right and it
sounds maybe kind of trivial but again
in big organizations it can be very
contentious and
and even if it's not contentious the
server people again it tends not to be
their sweet spot either and they might
make decisions about well I'll turn this
feature on and I'll leave that one off
that might create chaos and the greater
physical network and so we're trying to
figure out to get this ministry to end
as a as a community you know how do we
how do we address this problem most
efficiently and like most things in
networking there are competing
approaches just for the virtual switch
piece that's my my first two two rows
appear there are two sort of global
approaches and then there's three
implementations within that and they're
all actually two of them are
standardized although they're not very
well adopted in the first three what are
called network overlay technologies are
there working their way through the IETF
one is is it's actually two of them
since this company I know if you heard
of a company called nice Sarah they sort
of put the idea of virtual networking
and software-defined networking on the
map because VMware spent believe a
little over a billion dollars to acquire
them about a quarter ago so so before
they did that they were driving this
this overlay technology called VX LAN
which does a couple things it tunnels
that virtual machine traffic across an
existing network and it also extends the
number of virtual LANs that are
available in the environment so if
you're again if you're going to have
hundreds of thousands of virtual
machines the the traditional limit
limitation of 4000 virtual LANs just
Israel they hold up so but that's an
approach again it hasn't been
standardized yet there's a there's
there's evidence behind it but you might
know that Microsoft is trying to get
back into the end of this game obviously
they were you know and obviously are a
big server player but in in most server
environments virtualization is very
important so their solution called
hyper-v has its own virtual switch and
so it needs its own network overlay
technology again the startup called my
Sarah was working on a third one now
they're part of VMware so it
you have to be seeing how that's gonna
play out so that's that's the network
overlay is is again one part of the
problem for you know one set of vendors
if you will a different sort of the
problem that I spoke of earlier you know
who's gonna manage this this virtual
network that's that's a couple of
different vendors on the physical
hardware side both Cisco and HP leading
the two things called Ethernet virtual
bridging and that is basically disabling
if you will that virtual switch that
VMware or Microsoft or whoever the the
hypervisor manufacturer is and doing all
of the switch processing whether it's
spanning tree whether it's layer 3 on
the physical switch and so again these
technologies which were standardized by
a different standards body and again for
people that have only peripheral the
networking there's basically two
standards organizations that help drive
things and networking I Triple E which
obviously is responsible for a lot lots
of things beyond networking instead of
electrical engineering they do a lot of
electrical standards and the things that
start with 802 are usually related to -
something to do with with Ethernet and
as you can see by the the three letters
after the number we have all the
standards we can eat in at layer two so
and on the the Internet side so IETF
internet Engineering Task Force that's
where things are around the IP protocol
tend to be standardized and the
different process and and you know both
of these even though there's standards
bodies it you probably know the
standards bodies or tend to be occupied
by the same people right so a company
comes up with a technology they get
first mover advantage and then you know
after a while they decide to go out and
well maybe I'll standardize this to make
a little more popular I that's it tends
to be housed what's happened is either
industry and sometimes academia again
there you'll see some and I don't have
my list here but in the IETF there's
there's several Sdn standards being
promoted today and those tend to come
more out of the academic side of the
house so far
so that's that's the virtual switch
again sort of a subset of you know how
do we address the needs of the virtual
data center and the next one is what
will we call data center fabrics and
just sort of an illustration of of what
we mean by that so it's contrasted to
the three-tier architecture I showed
earlier so I eliminated a layer and
that's that's part of what a datacenter
fabric is but the other part of it is we
need to deploy different protocols and
I'll go back to what some of those are
so that I can eliminate the traditional
protocols and my three-tier architecture
which tended to disable about half the
links in my environment if I'm going to
have an effective data center fabric and
be able to move those virtual virtual
machines throughout the environment
wherever they need to go I need to again
flatten the fabric and speed it up and
be able to leverage more of my links and
so that's that's what I mean when I
refer to datacenter fabrics I'm showing
a couple different competing
architectures Q fabric is is the one
that juniper is working on this is the
trail architecture is being worked on by
some of the other big players in
industry HP Cisco and brocade are
working on on trail approaches to the
datacenter fabrics so so here's sort of
the the vendor approaches if you will to
the datacenter fabrics and those are all
I'll call them brand names for solutions
that the vendors sell there's actually
an both an I Triple E and an IETF
standard for this the the I Triple E one
is SP b stands for shortest path
bridging that one actually has not been
finalized yet and but you know and maybe
it'll alter how we do things and then
drill and and some of these
manufacturers will say that their their
solutions are based on trail but unlike
some of the existing standards like
spanning tree nobody's drill talks
anybody else's trail today so it's it's
it's definitely exactly it's a it's a
it's very customized standard if you
will so and the third piece is of
supporting the virtualized data center
is what we call data center interconnect
and what I mean by that is that we've
always had wide area communication
obviously the original ARPANET looked
something like this right we connected
various research institutions across the
country with the original ARPANET to
pass traffic but you know tcp/ip was
with standardized pretty early for in
that environment and things when they
went very far everything was a was a
layer three hop I looked up in the
routing table and I forwarded it to the
next hop and I looked up on the routing
table and again to build out these
virtual environments so that this
virtual machine can do live migration
from my primary data center deny it to
my backup data center I need to have a
layer to construct across this wide area
boundary so there's currently one
standard and it's it's a VP LS and it's
it's virtual private LAN service it's
layered on top of a MPLS circuit that
you can get from your your wide area
provider and that's what approach it's
it definitely works but there's a lot of
room for improvement so again going back
to my slide my my room for improvement
slide so there's there's a couple
different approaches that are these are
all very proprietary system has a couple
of one's called OTV once called lisp HP
came up with one called Evi and then VPS
I mentioned already exist and that was
pretty well
well adopted and there's a couple of new
ones called Mac VPN and Ethernet VPN so
trying to address some of the
shortcomings of a VP LS that to better
support these these virtual environments
so that's these are all obviously trying
to address a single component of the
overall challenge right so and it and
they all come at it with the the the
basic philosophy that networking has
always followed since I give development
of the ARPANET really is that we're
going to have a distributed environment
and so therefore we need to every device
in that invite
mint needs to have some sort of protocol
to talk to other distributor devices
share state figure out how to how to
forward a random packet right and so the
things that we're layering on top all
still follow that that basic premise of
how networks are designed and again
coming out of the the clean slate
program here at Stanford
there's been another approach which we
call software-defined networking which
says let's take a completely different
look at this and it says you know this
is this is how we've been building
packet data packet networks again since
the ARPANET with these three ideas as as
the the basic premise and this still
applies to all the emerging standards
that I just talked about whether it's V
X LAN or or or o TV or whatever they're
all still following this this basic
concept of for the data plane I'm gonna
every device has to make this an
individual decision about every every
packet that it sees and it's going to do
that based on some control plane
algorithm with whether it's a routing
algorithm like like B GPRO SPF and I've
got to communicate to my peers if the
topology changes and and really the
probably the biggest challenge is is
what we call the management plane and
that is somebody's got to configure all
this right and and it's and this is it's
kind of cumbersome and more importantly
in the virtualized data center in the
virtualized network it's not really
allowing innovation I mean there's
obviously the things that all the
vendors are working on and are their
innovation of a sort but the network
really is a service right the network is
some of the most call it plumbing right
we want it there but but what we really
want is the application right we really
want is the GPS after work we want our
Facebook to update we want to be able to
get the the Giants score when it starts
in half an hour all right we want to be
able to get these these services off the
network and we want the network to be
transparent and the people that are
developing the applications they want to
consider it as a utility they don't want
have to think about well you know how do
I get my application to the head of the
queue or how do I make sure that it
works across the center it's a
software-defined networking
even though it has to actually Software
Defined it working as defined in the in
the title but there's actually a lot of
definitions right now again the industry
is also starting to figure out what it's
going to mean long term but I found this
is actually put together by somebody at
Princeton alright this this is a really
good presentation that I found and it
really takes the sort of a fundamental
level fundamental approach to explaining
Software Defined Networking and
contrasting it to traditional networking
and this is really at the most
fundamental level what we mean by this
and it's it's abstracting out all that
control and in forwarding intelligence
up to a software layer and and pushing
out and have these the forwarding
devices just have an API to this and and
again that the vision is and it's kind
of where we are that there's obviously
some some labs going on and there's
definitely I mean Google made a big
splash right there doing some things
with data center back up with open flow
which is one implementation of Software
Defined Networking but but so far it's
it's still very much a fluid concept
about what it's going to mean in the
long term but what what the vision is is
that the application developers can now
start to write application things again
like look one of the examples is load
balancing so someone wrote a
software-defined network application and
they were able to push it out to this
research network actually the internet -
is the network they're using and he was
able to even out the spikes in in server
requests just by writing this this app
right and obviously it's still a
research environment and meaning that we
haven't already proved that it's going
to work at scale but it's it's a very
interesting concept than it could be it
could fundamentally change how we build
networks and you know again take it out
of the hands of companies like mine and
put it into the hands of the software
developers but you have to be seen where
it's going to go and in what form it's
going to take because because all of the
network manufacturers are all on record
is saying we support Software Defined
Networking but obviously everyone's
trying to figure out how do we take
something that wants to be open and
and and widely available and and so
forth and and make a business out of it
and I think that's that's where the
conflicts coming from so so basically
two two competing approaches to to try
and address the virtual data center and
I just wanted to go back briefly to to
the data center fabric which is what I
probably spend most of my time talking
to customers about this is whether
whether customers are virtualizing in
and actually some customers I mean big
companies actually they don't virtualize
but even if they if they're not
leveraging the the virtualization
technology that probably means they're
buying more servers and so they still
have a scale challenge which is how do I
connect more of these devices make their
services readily available
you know without being affected by
latency again back in the three-tier
architecture latency is it really
inhibits the ability to write robust
applications so if you're building out a
bigger website or a bigger application
you're going to have a web tier and an
app tier the database tier it's kind of
the classic tiers and what happens
whether you're virtualized or whether
you're physical those tiers of I'll call
them sub applications want to talk to
each other and if they have to you know
be hindered by an intermediate hop
that's going to slow them down
they tend not to work as well a lot of
these apps are written with the idea
that perhaps they're on a given physical
server and latency obviously is it can
be measured in nanoseconds and if I
spread them across a network and I
introduce latency no I the apps don't
work anymore and so data center fabrics
are interesting to customers again with
whether they're using virtual or
physical servers and in today you know
if you walk into any given data so do
people that are virtualizing tend to
have the big blade type servers people
that are not tend to get that what we
call pizza boxes but the more economical
almost disposable I'll say types of
servers but but the scaling is a
challenge on either front and so one of
the one of the approaches is is what
we've done at juniper is is taken
the idea of a physical chassis switch
and expanded it to support a data center
of 6,000 devices and so this is we call
the skew fabric and what we've done is
again taken the the concept of a
physical Ethernet switch chassis based
which we've been around for about 20
years and all these devices have some
sort of an internal switch fabric they
have the the modules where you plug in
the ethernet connections and then they
have some sort of intelligence whether
it's called a supervisory module or a
route engine and all these pieces slot
into the same sheet metal and and the
control protocols in the fourier tables
the control protocols are managed as
part of this this routing engine and
based on that based on the calculations
of the topology they push out that
information to the line cards to do
forwarding the challenge obviously with
with a given piece of sheet metal or a
given PCB with with traces is that you
can only get that so large right
typically so far it's like 42 ru is
about the biggest one I've seen right
once you get beyond a given rack in a
datacenter it's you need to come up with
something else and so the approach we
took was well let's abstract this idea
of a backplane out and make it a
separate device and let's make it
optical instead of instead of electrical
and let's take this idea of a line card
and make that a discrete device that's
going to connect to the back plate or
the interconnect the 40 gig fiber
connections and that's on top of that
again in the traditional chassis based
Ethernet switch most of the control
protocol happens again on the backplane
it shares the the switch infrastructure
with the data packets so there's some of
the packets are user information or
applications talking occations and some
of the the data inside this device is
the control protocols I'm I get a
spanning tree update I get a routing
update and so control and data are
interleaved
when you want to scale two to six
thousand devices in a data center six
thousand servers in a data center that's
that can
a lot of control traffic and so another
innovation that we took here was to
split that off into a completely
separate network and so control does not
share this high-speed data network we
just forward what I'll call user traffic
or application traffic on that and so
that in that way we're able to provide
that low latency that these applications
are using and so this is showing the
interconnects and this this is the top
of rack devices and by building
basically a very large abstracted
Ethernet switch I can now support
applications across an entire data
center and and serve up that low latency
that that these applications are looking
for could you go through this again I
don't I don't understand it what's in
that interconnect box absolutely so so
was the understand the traditional
chassis based Ethernet switch yes I
think so
so if you if you see cue fabric this
looks a lot like a traditional chassis
based Ethernet switch it has these are
actually 40 gig cue SFP ports on the
front and but it's another way to think
of it as it's a very simple core and an
intelligent edge and the processing is
again put off on what we call a control
Ethernet network and so the routing
updates switching updates multicast
updates they're gonna obviously they're
going to hit this intelligent edge and
control traffic is going to be off on a
Gigabit Ethernet network to the
intelligence to the that we call it the
director but call it the route engine or
the Supervisory piece of the environment
it's going to do the calculations and
it's going to push the forwarding
updates out to all these elements again
via the automatic control network and if
I then get a a user packet add a true
data packet the
decision about where it's gonna end up
is made here at the intelligent edge and
so there's you know a little very little
processing that happens here the this
device knows where it wants to go it
knows the topology and it's going to
have a little it's gonna have a
proprietary header on top of the
Ethernet frame and there's basically
this type of devices just a very simple
I'm gonna it comes in this port and out
that port so no other packet processing
so there's a crossbar I'm such in there
exactly is that just the control logic
is pretty simple
exactly and that allowed us to scale
again beyond what you can put in in one
physical 42 ru rack therefore they're 40
gig fiber yes exactly exactly which is
how we make it so low latency so that
interconnect does not turn the bits into
electronics it leaves them as photons
actually I think we know I think we do I
think it does go optical electrical
optical yeah there's it's not there are
devices obviously in the in the network
space that that just switch switch
lights
this is mrs. not yet we don't all bunch
of little mirrors inside thank you but
yes so yeah absolutely I I'm aware of
there's a few devices on the market that
do that where ours is not one of them we
do make that conversion introduce is
very little latency though and so so is
that exactly it when you say when I say
end-user I'm usually a sense of server
yes
these are gig and 10 gig ports so it's
it's more of a data center solution I
mean you could put it in if you could
hook up you know your desktop in the
campus environment we haven't seen any
use that way yet and that's mainly
because of currently the 40 gig can go
about 300 meters so it's still pretty
much a within a data center packed
solution it works
in order for us to serve up the low
latency that that is kind of required
for both of it forward to be
economically come
but also for it to work this the the the
distance limitation is again about 300
about data center scale so the servers
hang off of this node and again if you
were you know see this picture of it it
looks like a 1u top-of-rack Ethernet
switch and actually the devices that
we're using we can add mix you can have
two personalities they can actually be a
standalone top Iraq switch 1 to 10 gig
with some 40 gig or it can be what we
call a this qf node in this environment
so but yeah the the node is where the
server's attach we also I don't want to
get into it I didn't want to boil the
ocean but another thing in the
virtualized data center and you saw back
in the the tree environment is storage
used to be a separate network another
thing that's happening is that storage
is also becoming virtualized and storage
and and network are starting to converge
on the same infrastructure so there's
protocols like FCoE that are supported
here another reason I didn't talk about
it is that although the market this is
an area where the markets a little bit
ahead of the customers it customers are
a little bit wary about about
intermingling these two types of traffic
so if you if you've ever worked with a
storage area network it's it's much more
sensitive to loss because in a storage
area network it's actually doing block
level copying Ethan that's always been
best effort and so block level copying
and best effort don't don't go together
real well but that that's we are we both
juniper and the other players in the
industry are all building these
converged switches and we're sort of
waiting for the end-user to catch up
with us it's a little bit like I've
heard people compare it to when IP
telephony first came out the people at
large organizations were running the the
TDM voice network their proprietary
about their PBX is and and when Cisco
and Nortel back you know 12 years ago
came in and said hey you know we can
just run that voice stuff right on our
data network the people have been
already voiced for a long time said you
got to be kidding me so but of course
nowadays most most corporate phone
systems are running over overnight
Ethernet network and so this this this
convergence of of storage and network I
think will happen over the next five to
ten years as well no right and fast
there's another interesting word there
which is inexpensive back the previous
line Oh other backer oh what'd it look
like
huh no skip that one this one yeah
so these dumb fast switches are they
also inexpensive so that's it that's a
great question a lot of times when
people talk about network solutions
those are the usually the three
components right you have to pick two
right you want in in these examples it's
you want scale you want speed and you
want something economical and you could
pick a me-too right so so far the the
people that are coming to market with
and so far this is this is the open flow
piece of software defined networking
they are very alcohol to move in theory
so and they tend to be less expensive
than say juniper or Cisco's or brocade
kind of enterprise class which is that
they they put an open flow stack on
there and and Bush worked in silicon and
so they don't support a lot of these
these features that we used to support
right you know all these things take
obviously they they take the network
operating system code whether it's you
know iOS or Juno's and they take they
tend to take extra silicon the our
merchants are looking right all the big
manufacturers create their own Asics to
be able to do these things quickly and
so what that absolutely drives up the
cost of these switches and so the
approach here is that well let's not do
that on on the switch let's do it up
here and so the there's a couple of
startups that are that have come to
market with this one's called big switch
again
actually started great right here on
campus HP has a couple of devices that
do this and there's a couple of other
belief Korean startups that have what
they're selling as OpenFlow switches and
so they do tend to be less less
expensive then I probably not consumer
grade you know prices but compared to
traditional switches that are sold to
enterprises and data centers I would say
probably half of that 50% less so but
but the promise is that at least for the
people that are pushing on OpenFlow is
that this is you know what we call merch
and silicon meaning you know Intel makes
a switch component there's no OS it's
just basic forwarding and then they sell
people that want to productize they put
it in sheet metal and so on as meet the
net switch open flow so far is it's an
open source protocol right so so yeah if
people that are doing this these are
very very low-cost devices so but but so
far as far as I know there's get a lot
of interesting research projects going
on but this is it's definitely in the
science project stage so which is which
is a good thing but but it's it will
have to be pushed into I think real live
customer networks before we can see how
it how it you know works over time and
and how it works at scale so the science
part so I again I guess I wouldn't call
Google's backup Network a science
project but so most of the examples that
I've seen are again they're on internet
too and they are very controlled trials
so I guess that's that's the piece that
I'm that I'm calling science is that I
haven't seen anybody yet try to deploy a
thousand node data center what we
haven't tried it yet right so I'm not
saying that a can it's just nobody's
tried it yet people are there it were
very much in the proof-of-concept stage
again the I think what they've been like
to open flow / Sdn conferences that were
very much in the early phases and again
there's a lot of cool videos online from
from the clean slate Institute
and the the Open Networking foundation
they kind of show you what they're doing
it's just fascinating but all of them
are six nodes so that's why it when I
when I say when people are just kind of
seen seeing what's possible and get into
the scale piece is going to be the next
phase I think absolutely and there's so
the whole latency story of Google failed
500 Tom and I like this is the big thing
but I can trick them by turning on
iTunes so I think what what again these
are I didn't should have given credit to
the lady of principle put this together
but I think what what the DOM is
contrasting to what the devices today
are doing again enterprise class which
is they're making all these decisions on
every given packet right there they're
filtering there they're adding quality
of service they're you know maybe it's
you know high-end switches can can copy
a whole stream of traffic right that
that takes CPU that takes it takes more
silicon right they want to do things
like like S flow and net flow on
switches right so we want to meet or
what we're doing we want to show you
what the traffic profile looks like so
that's I guess that's what I mean
contrasting sort of so-called
intelligent device these these so-called
dumb devices they don't do any of that
they rely on on the controller or the
application to make most of the
forwarding decisions a little bit like
cue fabric where the the forwarding
piece the forwarding logic is not on the
data plane the NATO plane is just it
sees it it makes a few modifications if
need be if it does multicast replication
for instance but we try to keep
the processing to a minimum and let all
the that I should say the packet process
into a minimum and keep the control
processing on a separate device the you
know I gets the promise here and what
makes it interesting is that yeah we you
you you pull the intelligence out of
here so that you can afford to have you
know rich applications up here one
approach again
juniper we actually have our high-end
routers have an open flow stack so it
doesn't necessarily have to be but you I
think if you look at people that are
talking about why do I want to do Sdn
it's because I want to bypass the all
the complexity that not just beautiful
but in any high-end router manufacturer
has to put in to be able to support
large-scale route of networks so they're
definitely competing philosophies and
and even within like my company I talk
to the router guy up to the OpenFlow guy
right and they don't speak the same
language have the same vision so and
even it's you know I go in Cisco's
website it kind of is it kind of is if
you go to assist goes website layout one
guy talking about the X land and then
you've got their CTO of cloud talking
about and I don't and you don't get the
sense they work in the same building so
it's it's very interesting about about
where we are today then that's why I say
that's that's why when when my colleague
Benjamin talked me into doing this it's
like you know what do you what do you
what do you want out of the audience and
it really is you know I disagree with
the individual who asked who said you
know we're done we figured out
networking I think it really is a Tower
of Babel I think that and in order for
us to scale and and and keep enable in
the digital economy we need to figure
this out and and make it smarter faster
and cheaper because people want more all
the time and and right now more and more
people are seen than the network as a
hinderance not as an enabler so how do
you handle congestion in this
so I'm by no means an application
developer but I did watch this cool demo
on on on YouTube and again what this
what this individual did using some open
flow enabled devices on on the Internet
- he wrote this application and and they
showed a graph of a lot of variability
in latency in response time to web
requests was very spiky and he wrote
this application and and somehow it's
imposed load balancing and again I just
watched a video right it didn't didn't
read the white paper yet but and it was
before and after after it's just this
nice smooth line it's you know constant
latency so I don't know how he did it
but the idea is that ask the bank
predictable yeah but these loads are
fractal and you can't you have to
compensate on all time scales from
milliseconds today's and they absolutely
yes so the days go it happened in the
red block hmm but the milliseconds I
suspect have to happen when the searches
absolutely yep exactly which is why I'm
calling a science project which is why
I'm calling a science project I mean the
the the person who did this this
proof-of-concept it was a handful of
clients and a handful of servers and a
handful of switches and so I it's
definitely still in the research phase
and he you know they it it might not
scale and it I you know we have to go
back to all the competing standards for
virtualizing the data center
virtualization you know those things so
that's why I think they're pushing both
simultaneously or we are you know right
now if you won a 10 gigabit intrusion
detection thing for a million dollars as
opposed to you know a spare $50 you can
buy a switch that III thank you for
bringing that up that was actually I
as part of my talk but my was getting
was going three hours when I first put
it together because you know my
background I did a lot of network
security and juniper does a lot of
network security as well and that was
the whole thing right but to your point
when we developed the ARPANET the the
basic premise was that you trusted
everyone yeah and obviously we're kind
of at the the inverse of that now we
don't trust anybody on the network and
so a lot of these things that's a great
question
a great observation none of those those
virtual networking standards are taken
into account security it'sit's tends to
be still an afterthought and so I think
to really get where we want to be we
when we start developing these these
standards whether they're trill whether
they're you know evpn and even though
evpn has VPN in the name it's not
private because it's encrypted all right
it's private because it's sort of you
know masked if you will right which is
for people to secure people it's like
that's not really private so it's
actually a huge issue and to you're spot
on it gets back to the economics right
the more processing the higher you go in
the OSI model which you have to do for
intrusion inspection you need more CPU
cycles but I think I think we need to
take as an industry a different approach
and start baking security in and how we
do things and we're I don't think we've
done that yet so that's it's a very
important point I believe and one thing
that's been bothering us a lot lately is
if you go take anybody's cloud farm out
there you know you can't just go look at
the north-south traffic going to the
outside world and protect that you you
you know that stuff maybe we can scale
enough to get some control over it but
the amount of east-west between all the
ugly things people are running on Amazon
for instance you know can you how much
it so that's another excellent point so
actually this slide I took out of one of
my my Juniper slide decks and the topic
was and I actually I actually modify it
because I just wanted to show you simply
we actually make a product that sits
here it's a firewall yeah and so you're
split but it's still you know from again
from an industry perspective that's it's
it's kind of a an overlay if you will
baked on on top of this there really we
should somehow I totally agree we need
to bake it in is clear with new
standards like the VX land well how
about a security component we tend not
to think in those terms too
today security 10 tends to be an
afterthought which is great for start-up
for this right there's a lot of great
security startups because there's so
much opportunity because people don't
think to make it in at the beginning but
I think that if we you know the next
iteration of standards we should
probably think about notion let's think
about privacy and let's take a little
bit more about about hashing so that we
have the integrity and I I agree it's
it's definitely very much after we build
this big fast network oh wait a minute
where'd my information go right every
look nobody wants to be in the news
foreheads I just lost a hundred thousand
user IDs bad so no it's a great point so
that's that's all I had any other any
other questions 6,000 nodes that's large
but it's not very very long what do you
do beyond that that's a fabulous
question too so that's six thousand ten
gig servers and you're right there
definitely we've actually already talked
to a few customers that have big
rendering farms and in environments
where they want more than that so if if
you especially if you I'm more familiar
as you might imagine with the junipers
technology than some of the others but
so with the technology what we have to
know with queue fabric I have a maximum
of these for these interconnects in 128
of the the nodes which is how I get my
my six thousand odd servers there's no
reason that you know this architecture
can't scale beyond this right so today
these are 40 gig links they can go to
100 gig all right there's no reason I
can't have more interconnects and more
nodes I should say there's no there's no
technical reason the the Rd budget to
get from this to the next level is is
considerable and actually to date
believe it or not I I agree there's
environments the were they need more
than 6-thousand the addressable market
if you will for six thousand at a time
is pretty finite at least so far and so
juniper actually this pretty pretty big
R&D investment in this solution so I
think and
so we have run into enough customers
that max this out and connecting two
together is not viable that they need
the the next level of iteration
it'll by be a while before we bring at
the market but I think the fundamental
technology will scale to we when we
initially launched the product actually
we were talking about when this goes to
100 gig and going to more interconnects
and at least a 10,000 nodes so we've
we've kind of got the the sketches if
you will of how to get - I'll call it
double that number beyond that that's a
great question
so but if you need to network that big
come come talk to us and we'll go we'll
go talk to the pot of guys and see what
they can do so but I know right now I
know what's what's what's slowed down or
at least our development is is what
we've seen so far is that even the
consumers for a 6,000 node environment
this is it's it's been pretty limited so
far so other questions so there's this
fundamental problem you got to do
something one when a link is overloaded
right there's all those links that can
get overloaded absolutely so are you
dropping packets or are you pushing back
to the guy you know further upstream
saying wait a bit that's another great
question so in so it's a question I
meant to ask I'm sorry
so there's a couple different things so
we have a couple different versions of
this node and one of them you can have
as many connections to the interconnect
as you have connections to servers so
zero oversubscription
and so at least from I know you're
saying I know you're saying you can
still the more if more requests can get
to the end node device well if I've got
three servers all sending to the same
it's gonna have you bottleneck someplace
it just may not be a bottleneck in your
backbone it'll be a bottleneck right it
right it the connection to that exactly
exactly
no absolutely absolutely but so there's
there's two levels absolutely so there
was when I was
getting it out was that we can design
this so the default design the 6000
servers actually is three to one
oversubscription
so there's we're assuming that you're
not trying to push like you're not an
HPC at six thousand nodes obviously if
you're gonna be a higher performance
compute cluster you want one to one then
we can support that not but not to 6,000
nodes but yeah so to your point I mean
this is it this is an intelligent edge
so what I mean by intelligent is that we
can do QoS and so forth so but yeah at
the end of the day if more requests come
in and then don't come in then yeah
backups are gonna fall on the floor
absolutely it's so it's it is the
default design is oversubscribed and so
again with the the design assumption is
that you're not going to have all these
servers run in a 10 gig you know 100
sent the time so I guess from that
perspective it's no different than then
you know going back to a bus space
network right you have to back off and
go higher up the stack and re transmit
and all those things so I guess from
that from that perspective there's the
the magic of this is that we can have a
much larger l2 domain and have it spread
across a larger environment at low
latency but the reality of
oversubscription still exists and the
reality of yeah you have to you have to
drop packets at some point so yeah we
have it we haven't alter that calculus
yet if more requests come in and then we
can process at the same time you mean
the picture overall improve with your
approach or really gets worse but I
practice all right it definitely got
automatically worse right you may not
have to be that bad more opportunities
to screw up
right I just wondered what you saw so
far that you Express
predicted typical behavior really
familiar with or really get better worse
so I think for environments were there
where they're facing that a lot that
since you can design it for for no
oversubscription that at least in that
environment where i have as many
connections in is out so i don't at
least over subscribe this device yeah
oopah it back on at least back on the
server to to moderate the request of the
replies so so I'm gonna say it's it's
better because I can be a low latency
you know transparent transport and that
can be not oversubscribed so I'm gonna
say let me say that parts better but
you're absolutely right there's still
possible for the servers to make more
requests than they could be processed by
the network so exactly sometimes make it
something when the load increases the
throughput goes down because I've been
doing right sure yep and that's where
that's what most networks are counting
on right the network's counting on
exactly I exactly know the network it's
definitely counting on higher layer
higher layer protocols to exactly to
back off
yes with protocols that I told you to do
one thing and reward doing the opposite
exactly so the other interesting can of
worms and recent networking is buffer
bloat what do you mean by that Moore's
Law is is gone overboard you can now get
low cost devices right that have seconds
worth of buffering right right
absolutely and and the infrastructure
doesn't do the right thing
so I've measured six second round trip
time on my simple little DSL line Wow so
I haven't I haven't heard of it that
terminology but I there are customers
some of these big social networking
companies for example their applications
use something called memcache and it
definitely pushes the boundaries of the
buffer space on a standard Ethernet
switch and there's been a couple
startups in the networking space that
have built products just to address that
but like a lot of things going back to
the the software-defined networking
slide you can't it's hard to do that
with a dumb switch because buffer on a
switch is by definition it's it's
silicon right so you got to add memory
you got to add something to be able to
store those packets so the drippers so
far has it really come over we caught
you people call a deep buffer switch but
they do it's just in the market so it's
not gonna solve all the problems but
unless that's that's the point it makes
it worse okay if I don't have a lot of
buffering right then then I can't build
up the queues so that they get to my way
right it's it's when I have something
like forest traffic coming through
right okay but but somebody poked the
browser button and the browser opened 47
connections right okay and all of those
guys dumped a big pile of crap in here
and the switch isn't smart enough to
figure out that that the voice traffic
should jump ahead of all that crap right
great
this restructure is not right so there's
a couple of pricing a couple different
actually rich customer right I've seen a
lot of customers they deploy voice over
IP and the whole promise was supposed to
be that you could have a shared
infrastructure I've seen a lot of
customers it's like yeah and we're gonna
do that they have a voice data network
in a day to day to network just for that
very reason that but if the environments
would dump with memcache than the big
data centers the pretends not to be a
lot of voice but for the for mixed
environment it does get back to you know
the doing here less processing and
ingress and
you know giving voice priority so again
not perfect but which is why some people
are building dedicated voice Ethernet
networks but yeah that's there's no
question that that that's an ongoing
challenge based on how we build this
technology it's a great another great
point you're calling me all the things I
thought about that I couldn't figure out
how to put in this so so my background
is I've done what I really call
enterprise networks data centers and
campuses absolutely so you know all
these devices especially the ones that
are on AT&T of Verizon's network all
right there's a whole other piece of the
network right this it's that's mobile
backhaul that's cellular that I've I had
very little experience with but you're
absolutely right that creates its own
constraints on the network and its own
demands and definitely not my my
wheelhouse so I'm but but I will say I
mean juniper as a company a big part of
what juniper does is is work with the
Verizon's and the ATM teas and the
Deutsche Telekom trying to solve the
problems that they have of and Comcast
right supporting more subscribers higher
speeds lower latency and that's a whole
different set of technologies again it's
not my wheelhouse on I won't embarrass
myself by trying to talk about it but I
totally agree that this is definitely
sort of one side of the equation that
side is just as important and probably
more noticeable to the average user who
like how come I don't have a connection
my how come I get my email on my phone
right so okay I wasn't sure of some of
these software-defined network so I
think they do actually so the research
I've been doing into Sdn it there's
definitely so again Google was one of
the first to come out publicly and say
hey we built this this backhaul network
for ourselves using open flow and from
the it's called the open open network
foundation that horizon was one of the
speakers
somebody from Verizon and they were very
keen on on using software to find out
working as well so again not not my my
skill sets uh but but I do know that
there is very much interest because they
wanted to drive down cost to one of the
slides that he showed
it's actually one that we use at juniper
and it's showing me you know the cost to
vote in the network and the you know the
the revenue per subscriber right and so
what she gets crazy that you don't make
it up on volume as we all know right so
so they the service providers are just
as interested in figuring out how to how
to solve these problems elegantly and
economically as big enterprises and big
data centers are so great observation
though absolutely and and part of that
was so this is so cute fabric we
advertise microsecond latency and that
supports most most things people are
doing at data centers today latency is
most important in in a couple of at
least from an economic percenter pay to
make it less Wall Street so people that
in trading environments because you can
actually get a competitive advantage if
you can trade a little faster than the
other guy so they would love you know
latency of nothing you know and they'll
pay for they'll pay for another another
man a second of latency improvement I
think in the trading environments in
other places if you're building these
big data centers and you want to
distribute these applications that again
want very instant response time from
there again from the SA from the app
tier to the database tier it it's it's
it's in the in the in the nanoseconds
that we're striving to to get to today
so that's another reason I didn't want
to talk about it with the virtual
switches because they're based on server
architecture they tend to have higher
latency as well even with within the
given physical server you think well
it's virtual and it's on the server it
should be fast but it's those buses
inside of a physical server weren't
really optimized for network traffic for
network packets and so then actually
it's not as efficient as pushing it out
to a physical switch and let it process
and you know pushing it back on a by
hypervisor so again the products in the
market today that are considered low
latency or are a couple of nanoseconds
is what we
about so but it's that a port I mean
obviously for checking your email I mean
there's there's height we talked about
how to have a protocol some of them are
very tolerant of delay right the 30
seconds I'll check again right but it's
more of these it's somewhat niche and it
but it's also somewhat inside the data
center again apt a database and so forth
that that are very latency sensitive but
it's not by all means not every
application is super latency sensitive
so anything else oh thank you
you